coli e was gleich eins aufs maul ich
sehe nahm ich den namen philipp adorf
freuen und herzlich willkommen back to
minecraft war o 3 j und beck auf den
fileservern die dritte folge mit dabei
ist und keiner hat uns nach gateway ab
jetzt bist du schon drin ich bin schon
drauf
okay es geht los mit den herren mit
unserem hammelfleisch wir haben auf
jeden fall schon ein bißchen mehr ich
würde sagen wir lassen das jetzt aber
erst mit 15 fleisch das müsste erstmal
reichen gibt es noch etwas was sonst
kräften müssen erstmal ne eigentlich
nicht lassen auch das eben okay dann
haben wir da noch eins geben wir das
eben raus das fleisch dann nehme ich den
ofen mit der ofen mit und jetzt ab dahin
in die richtung und jetzt das versuchen
irgendwie höhle reinzukommen
auf jeden fall alles andere mitnehmen
ganz toll auf patienten ist ein skelett
laufen mal eben kurz im boden rum dass
man die schweine schafe und hinten kurz
schafe seien
wir müssen dieser folge echt sehr viel
reis wir müssen sehr sagt erlösten
wirklich in der menge sondern wirklich
besser gespielt und nicht dabei springen
in der tat
okay noch ein paar schafen mitnehmen ich
nehme mal irgendwie die kohle mit tollen
leuten die ich schon mal ob du
irgendwann denkt sie ist irgendwo eine
hülle balkon ist ja auch mal wichtig um
die sachen dann letztendlich verarbeiten
zu können in der tat liest du irgendwo
was ja ich bin jetzt einfach nur
geradeaus weiter gelaufen
hinter die nicht so richtig
ja okay ich werde das mit ihm weiter da
könnten noch weiter noch weiter
geradeaus einfach da glaube ich sind
hüllen
[Musik]
ich dachte schon ich hätte dich
geschlagen aber friendly fire zum glück
aus dass münchen
[Applaus]
ja okay da hinten sehe ich noch sehr
viel kür vielleicht sollten wir die auch
noch mitnehmen
elsendorf pauli was das alter der ist
alleine oder oder weil sie nicht ja das
alleine da kommt zu mir wo bist du
einfach geradeaus weitergehen
bist du sicher dass meine ist ja es ist
da ich will dich lass uns mal hier
rechts lassen dorf ja deswegen
dassendorf aber hier rechts ist halt
eine höhle und so der ist aber ein
matter fucking dorf lasst uns erst mal
das dorf auschecken alter vielleicht
irgendwas dann hole ich schon richtig
gut ist und der und beide platten sind
jetzt ja aber die sind ja wahrscheinlich
nicht hier ja das sagst wir ja die map
ist riesig wo bist du ich bin einfach
gelaufen ich bin auch im village oder
ich sehe da habe ich den namen villiger
dorf ja das bin ich zum glück wirst du
das alter mein gott lass uns bitte in
der höhle alter ja aber wenn es dann
eine schmiede gibt dann haben die da
richtig krasse sachen dann liegen da
immer diamanten drin rum und so ich will
trotzdem in der höhle alter ich denke
nur kurz ab ob in der höhe
guck mal da sonst das richtig viel essen
wir müssen zu diesem dorf wir müssen das
ausschenken das ist einfach meine
erkunder laune erkunden ist eine höhle
okay die leitung der visto wo bist du
hier stehe ich ich selig tätig dann
lassen die höhe gehen hier sind halt
richtig viele sachen die du fressen
kannst ja ich gucke in den häusern ist
ja nichts drin irgendwie darf
wenn heute in köln sein kommen hier
abseits vom vom dorf hier sind richtig
viele tiere dann haben wir sowohl saab
seit welche richtung abseits
wo bist du denn die rede wo wir gelaufen
sind von der wiese gekommen sind laufen
die richtung von der wir gekommen sind
oder wo bist du gerade
[Musik]
ich sehe ich aber nicht stets auf der
freien fläche
jetzt bin ich auf der freien fläche lauf
links lena wo bist du hier genau jetzt
geradeaus einfach geradeaus ich konnte
natürlich ja und hier ist eine höhle bei
mir okay ja perfekt ja hier sind halt
auch noch tiere wartet dann lasst uns
tötet man das schwein dann noch schweine
sind erstmal wichtiger oder ich glaube
schafe geben genauso viel und hier ist
jetzt der höhleneingang hier stieß
braune wolle hier ist braune wolle komme
hier zu mir
hier ist der höhleneingang das nämlich
eine richtige höhle hier ist auch eine
richtige höhle aber da waren brauner
wolle blog das hat mich jetzt eher
verwundert
ok al asiri ändern
und jetzt beeilung definitiv definitiv
nein
die fahrpreise alte eisen ist so wichtig
in der tat die duma schon mal weiter ja
was nicht wir müssen die fakten die wir
bauen okay die hilde schon wieder zu
ende
ja ok aber ok dann lasst uns die nächste
reingehen am besten echt beim abbauen
und so auch immer es nicht dass
irgendwer kommen sollte oder irgendwie
sowas 3 1 habe ich schon mal oder vier
oder so
ich bin wieder oben geboxt
nicht richtig aus ja ich habe gerade
noch die dings mitgenommen was ist wenn
einer kommt
ich habe mir glauben oder hoffen wir
einfach laufen die andere hier ist auch
hier vorne ist eine hier ihr hier ist ja
ok
es wird keiner kommen also ich sehe
jetzt auch kein am horizont wie gesagt
die maps hat riesig man denkt sich immer
sowohl das ist eine eingegrenzte map
aber es ist halt schon groß ja die höhe
es auch schon wieder vorbei aber ich
habe auch schon wieder reisen gefunden
hier vielleicht hast du ja ich habe
zehn kinder zur welt schon mal eine
kleine rüstung machen ja oder ein
schwert das mal kurz die rheinländer
pickups erst jetzt kontraproduktiv komme
hier ein umbau hinter uns zu mit
irgendwas außer com ist okay dass ich
hier erde ja weil sie nicht irgendwas
oder ende seid oder moldawier keiner
kommt man sieht ja nichtmal namen
vielleicht kriegen wir das auch
hinterher aber das denke ich nicht
doch scheißegal kommen meine reisen
bringt auf jeden fall schon mal dann
können wir uns zwei schwerter packeisen
am besten auch noch ein eisen habe mich
alter da kann etwas abgebaut
ich habe gerade jemanden was abbauen
gehört oder das waren scharfen das waren
scharf wie gerade der auch so ein schaf
das hat wahrscheinlich aber die erde
oben gegessen weil sonst hätte man den
armen gesehen okay ich mache schon mal
das erste schwert wie viel man das
nächste eisen raus was da gleich raus
kommt wird man das mal zu
es schlägt neben der theke jeder von uns
hat schon mal so ein eisen schwert ich
weiß nicht was ist jetzt wichtiger eisen
der spezialsägen schafik spitzer gewicht
jedoch gut aufheben
ja aber nur eine brauchen wir dann
leider kann man kann sich einer auf
jeden fall schonmal rüstungsteile machen
hier ist noch was zu essen was ich mir
noch was fürs alter ich hatte das schon
wenn jemand anderes einfach auf dem
server ist dann ist man direkt 44
vorsichtiger was ist alles gut
ich habe gerade das liegt und abgedrückt
dann öffnet sich ja die das
auswahlsystem da okay ich mache uns mal
noch eine spitzhacke jetzt eben dh wir
haben jetzt noch neun eisen da kann man
sich schon mal eine brust platz oder
zwei helfen will aufgeregt ich bin
richtig aufgeregt war ja genau das ist
gut klappen am besten bisschen weiter
dass wir schon mal irgendwo vielleicht
noch mehr reisen finden
das können wir erst mal machen person
herunter
okay wir dürfen aber nicht die ganze
zeit hier verweilen weil sonst in der
nächsten folge der lieder sind wir drei
folgen vor was zu nehmen wir einfach
nach der ersten folge noch eine auf dann
kann ja niemand wissen wo wir sind
er ist irgendwie komisch warum so eine
komische fragen als wäre hier licht was
als welche licht ja guck mal hier unten
haben die steine so eine komische farbe
[Musik]
dass irgendwas zu bedeuten ich bin ja
ein lob ich kämpfe das sind teilweise
grafikfehler das könnte sein okay beim
lag bei mir der stoff erregt wenn wir
hier unten ist nichts ich nehme das
eisen raus ich mach jetzt etwas kaputt
gegangen
ja meine spielzeug so richtig paranoia
ich mach mir mal ein eisen brustpanzer
okay da mach' dir das mal erkläre ich
denke das ist sehr wichtig für mich
machen wir mal hast du noch reisen da
drin
ich habe keine angst ich hab alles sagen
ja ok ja keine ahnung hier geht es auch
irgendwie nicht weiter also ich finde
jetzt zumindest nichts gerade keine
gegenstände oder so da müsste man
wahrscheinlich noch viel weiter runter
gehen aber ich bin mir der typ der in
höhenrain läuft und sich da was holt und
ich er wäre denn es soll auch
arbeitstechnisch viel sinnvoller und da
hinkriegt man auf dem weg noch tiere und
so habe ich habe ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen angst weil holly und diesen
halt drauf sind
deswegen würde ich sagen hier jetzt
erstmals saints ein bisschen rum graben
und so eventuell da sind wir auch schon
relativ tief dass ich denke nicht dass
wir unseren namen sehen werden
ich habe ihn auf eine höhle gestoßen
wurde fackel ist mein gott bitte als ob
er die frage ist ob das gut ist
beispiel ich mal
wenn dann eine fackel drin ist es
bestimmt nicht gut deswegen sind sogar
zwei fackeln ja dann sollten wir
eventuell woanders hingehen kann ich da
unten ja scheiße hier machen wir ja das
ist halt die frage jetzt ist dass jemand
der um service ist das von uralten
folgen risiko oder safety
[Musik]
was definiert unter risiko das problem
ist wenn da halt fackeln sind dabei in
der höhle schon jemanden dann bringt hat
risiko nichts ja ich würde sagen wenn
ich ehrlich bin ja das ist ja echt blöd
dass wir schon fackeln sind dann gehe
ich davon aus dass hier auf jeden fall
schon mal war
obwohl da hinten sind keine mehr
ja das hatte ich da hatte ich mich auch
gefragt wieso hier hinten dann keine
sind erst erweisen müssen nochmal immer
an die decken schauen ob da irgendwas
ist links weiter gegangen
ja ich guck mal hier rechts was da noch
ist hier ist ein erster fall okay recht
ist auch nicht mehr nicht mehr gewesen
da waren nur noch wasser voll jetzt auch
nichts mehr
wie viel eisen hast du damit genommen 30
ok ich nehme doch hier geht es noch okay
bringen am besten schon mal das eisen
hoch und lasst das braten in der dings
werden noch vier minuten aufnahmezeit
das heißt vielleicht könntest du denn
noch
nochmals oder irgendwie sowas machen so
ging es nochmal hier an der decke ist
noch alles ab da kann ich machen klar
irgendwo einer seite war so ein eingang
von uns gut ich baue das eisen ab als
wäre ich ein eiserner bauer scheiße
alter ich habe richtig angst weil die
beiden auf dem server sind aber das legt
sich irgendwie ein bisschen zog dann
gehts ja ich habe auch ich muss wirklich
sagen ich habe es so lange keinen
allerdings mehr gezockt keinen minecraft
pvp oder sowas ja fragt mich mal du
willst egal wo bist du denn oben weil
kannst du mal kurz kleine treppe runter
kommen mich holen
ich weiß nicht mehr genau wo der weg war
da ich komme ok ich sehe dich aber
erstmal und häufig war der erwartete
moment ist ihm an
[Musik]
doch wie lang haben wir noch wir haben
gar nicht mehr so lange wir haben noch
zwei minuten denke ich deswegen jetzt es
geht da hinten hast du denn ich habe
frei sei bist du da hinten noch mal
weiter suchen wie machen wir es damit
kommt zu mir da wo die kisten standen
[Musik]
aber auch ruhig kommen hier mit runter
wieder am besten hinter dem namen
braucht eigentlich nicht zu bauen
[Musik]
hier könnte ich zu bauen ist nämlich so
na ja genau das ganze mal an
jetzt am letzten ball hinter uns zu mit
ende seite und sogar hinter uns zu
bitten was mit hier mit diesen blöcken
schmeißt jetzt mit denen auch das gute
zu geben mit der innstadt ich hab den ja
ich hab's dir auch zugeschnitten
dann haben wir jetzt nämlich so eine
kleine fläche dann kann ich schon mal
kisten den ganzen scheiß aufstellen dass
auf jeden fall schonmal geschäft ist so
kiste hast du noch holz naja ok ich
manchmal bitte schneider heute zu
bewegen hinter dir
[Musik]
mag alles in eine kiste packen alles in
eine kiste so was brauchen wir nicht
wollen dass sie sand leder lack alles
rein aus erschwert und so aber ich
könnte da sein
ist es vielleicht bis 15 sekunden gelegt
ja ich habe gerade ob ich noch irgendwas
brauche ich was vergessen noch zu machen
wir sind sehr ich glaube nicht wir haben
alles noch mal bei uns im werk abgebaut
nicht deswegen in der wand spawn wo wir
haben die dritte folge auch überlegt
freunde das war das ziel umsatz hier war
wirklich noch eigentlich noch viel mehr
eisen zu finden aber ich habe jetzt auf
jeden fall schonmal brustpanzer du
kannst dir noch einen helm machen
nächster volk und ich hoffe dass er dann
in der nächsten folge führung gehen
können
und nochmal ganz viel eisen finden die
nächste folge findet ihr auf wieder
beiden kanälen sowie diese folge das
heißt wenn jetzt aus halo tricks nicht
sehen wollt könnt ihr bei uns
vorbeischauen